une cellule du f.lq la cellule
libération le 5 octobre 1970
l'enlèvement de James Witcher cross
marque le début d'un pont important de
l'histoire du Québec la crise d'octobre
un événement pivot aussi dans la vie
d'un leader étudiant de l'époque Jacques
caussey Trudel
membre de la cellule libération du fait
le cul il fait partie avec sa conjointe
de l'époque Louise lancto des ravisseurs
du diplomate britannique est-ce qu'on va
retenir de lui c'est que il a été très
actif c'est pas un exécutant le loin de
là c'est quelqu'un qui qui avait des
idées qui discutaient
l'indépendance totale des Québécois mais
le militant idéaliste se retrouve
rapidement dépassé par les événements la
mort du ministre Pierre Laporte est une
douche froide ça avait été fait de façon
assez naïve l'enlèvement puis on se
retrouve avec l'arnaud Québec la loi du
maire de guerre les explications
politiques épouvantables et oui on se
sent pris dans la souricière on voudrait
pouvoir retourner chez nous c'est-à-dire
retourner au Québec si Jacques Rudelle a
été présenté à l'époque comme un
terroriste son ancienne épouse juge
essentiel de relativiser
d'une part était pas quelqu'un de
violent ni de radical la mort de la
porte celle-là énormément troublé dès le
moment il a été question d'éliminer
cross et qu'on a illuminé de fait la
porte
c'était fini entrevue Jacques me dit dès
ce moment-là j'avais honte d'être dans
le vécu
l'automobile prend place dans un cortège
les ravisseurs négocient la libération
de leur otage et obtiennent sur conduit
pour Cuba le début d'un exil de 8 ans
lorsqu'il rentre au Québec en 1978
Jacques possède Rudelle souhaite tourner
cette page de son histoire
après un procès et une incarcération
l'homme estime avoir payé sa dette mais
le stigmate lui collera la peau toute sa
vie comme tu es marqué au fer rouge même
quand on essayait de sortir de ça
d'avoir une autre vie ça nous revenait
toujours alors faute de pouvoir se
débarrasser de la crise d'Octobre
j'accot cette Trudel avait décidé de se
la réapproprier depuis quelques années
il travaillait sur un documentaire
fiction pour raconter ça version des
faits il avait dit je veux absolument
que la vérité sorte pour une fois et je
vais la dire coûte que ici Jean-François
Bélanger Radio-Canada Montréal